ふっ（笑）
（悪の科学者のような笑い方のまねをしている　Dr.ハジメ）
はははっ（笑）
あははははは（笑）
はは...
俺はついに見つけてしまった
簡単にできることを僕は、見つけてしまいました
その商品は！こちら！
見たことありますでしょうか？
こちらカラビナなんですけども
ただのカラビナではない
キーリングが伸びるタイプのカラビナです
普通のカラビナはさ
ここにこうパチパチってやってここにさ、何かをさー
例えばこういう所にね、パチッとして
こういう感じで
でここに色々鍵をつけるんですけど
ここが伸びます。こういう風に。
伸びるんで鍵が開けやすいんです。こうね。
ほう！
今のを見てわかったか？君たち
このカラビナリール、
それもかなりのスピードで
見ましたか？この...
ここから...このスピードですよ？
このスピード
多少の重りがあっても戻ってきます
これは使えるよ
これは使える
そう。私は気づいてしまった。
これを使って僕...
瞬間移動できるんじゃないか
この鍵が一瞬にして、
ここにいく
この動き、
まさしく、
この瞬間移動を人間でするためには
たくさんのカラビナリールが必要になると思いました
今回こちらにカラビナリールを100個
準備しました
ま、さすがに私もわかってますよ
自分の体重ぐらい
僕の体重だと絶対これ一つだと
僕の体重は支えれないので
カラビナ100個を準備して
カラビナリング100個を僕の体につけて、
伸ばして、
ある場所に全部ひっかける
で、誰かに僕を支えてもらって、
その人が離した瞬間...
僕は...
この、一瞬で瞬間移動するのができるんじゃないかと
思いまして
今回は人間が、引力を使って瞬間移動する実験です
では、いこう！
ひとまずベルトに全部通します
たくさんつけるので
ベルトに100個つける場所がないので、
こちらの小さいカラビナを準備しました
こうゆう感じで、ここにたくさんつなげていって
これ本体をベルトにつけます
あ、やばいわ、これ
うお！やっば！！
え、待って待って（笑）
あ、やばいやばい
いや、いくね？これ
絶対いく！絶対いく！
すげー！これ！
本気で作ったさ、
立体起動装置って感じじゃない？
ワイヤーアクションだぜ
もう完全に（笑）
完成しました！
この重量感！
これすべて、カラビナです！
まとめやすいように
カラビナリールを一つのカラビナに一個ずつつけていって、
バランスよく、こうゆう感じにしました！
これで僕の体にも着けやすいと思います
はーい！というわけで完成しました！
伸びる仕組みになっております
うっ
こちらの瞬間移動装置を、
一個ずつここに
このベルトにとりつけていきます
これを全部つけて、
僕が誰かに引っ張ってもらって、
で、それを離した瞬間、
僕は...
という瞬間移動ができるってわけでございます
では、つけていきましょう！
完全に完成しました
これを今から僕の腰に巻いて、かつ、
今目の前にある柱にくくりつけて、
ひっぱってもらって、
離した瞬間...
モンスターストライク...
はい、というわけでバッチリ完成しました
いや、まじで絶対瞬間移動しますから
ではっ！
よろしくお願いします！
いくぞっ！
OK！
あー、すごい
すごいすごいすごい！
すごい！
ヤバイ！
オッケ！オッケ！
ヤバイ！ヤバイ！
すごい！すごい！
すごいっ！
待って！ほんとにすごい！ほらっ！
ほらっ！ほらっ！
あーもう限界だ
準備が完了しました
今、MAXまで伸びております
これで離した瞬間、
カラビナの強力な引力に僕は吸い込まれて
壁に、瞬間移動します
では、いきますっ！！！
こうして、
はじめしゃちょーの、筋トレ生活が始まった
彼は、大量のカラビナリールを使って、
腕力、
脚力
全ての筋力をMAXまで鍛えあげ、
神になった